hey guys good morning well as you can
imagine the scene down here looked much
different last night than it does here
this morning the energy was palpable not
even the bitter cold could keep people
home as hundreds of fans came down here
to Rogers Square outside of the Halifax
Convention Center to cheer on Team
Canada and take a look at the Golden
Goal
[Applause]
liberations inside and outside the
Scotia Bank Center were heard all over
downtown Halifax last night the game was
played in front of a sold out crowd and
it was a standing room here only in
Rogers Square for those who couldn't get
their hands on those elusive tickets
taking in the final on big screen TVs
and all that fan support must have done
its work this is Canada's second
straight gold medal at the world juniors
Dylan Gunther scored the Golden Goal in
the thrilling 3-2 overtime win over
chechia and here's what fans had to say
moments after Canada clinched gold
how do you feel amazing this is
incredible to watch on the big screen
with all these people it's just insane
it's just unreal oh it's unreal history
I can't I can't even describe it that's
Canada baby
as you can see the atmosphere down here
was absolutely electric so nice seeing
all those fans enjoying themselves in
true patriotic form and now the
tournament is being widely seen as a
huge success in both host cities of
Halifax and Moncton but unfortunately
Canada will not get to defend gold next
year on home soil they'll be taking the
tournament across the pond where the
world juniors will take take place next
year in Sweden back to you guys
as they said last night ambra took 20
years to get this tournament back it's
going to be less than 20. that we're
going to get it again based on how
successful this was Amber Friday for us
at Rogers Square this morning downtown
and let's continue our coverage of the
world junior hockey fans have been
decked out in red and white it's been a
constant in the city of Halifax since
the start of all this as Megan King
reports the success of the event is
being contributed in part to those fans
and the atmosphere of Atlantic Canada
awesome Halifax been an awesome
atmosphere this week the event is being
praised as a resounding success by local
business owners visitors and politicians
alike I'm excited about the mood around
the city I think it's been a great way
to start the year restaurants of all
kinds you know businesses have done well
the hotels not usually really busy time
in most Canadian cities the first week
of January so this is a great bonus
described as a loud and electric
environment by visitors much of the
tournament's success is being attributed
to the fan-focused atmosphere provided
by the Atlantic coast cities feels great
I mean it's such an honor for Halifax
you know have the chance to post such an
event I mean
our fans are great like we get we get
really loud we chant a lot so it's fun
to fun to watch it's a great father-son
experience and it's something we'll
we'll watch it on TV for years to come
but this is probably the only time we
get to come in person HRM mayor Savage
says he's been told by the IIHF and
Hockey Canada that they're over the moon
with excitement about how well it's gone
we knew we could do it we just knew we
haven't hosted the World Junior since
0-3 we're the only city I believe that's
hosted the World men's the world women's
and the world juniors we just wanted a
chance to show again that a junior
hockey City could host the World Junior
Championships High ticket sales
throughout the tournament has meant more
people downtown and more money being
spent and that's a big win for the city
Megan King Global News Halifax